police are praising two good Samaritans
who help find a kidnapped eight-year-old
girl
investigators say Salim Sobotka was
abducted on Saturday CBS this morning
national correspondent Jericka Duncan is
in Forest Hill Texas where this little
girl has been found and she's safe
dareka this is the best possible outcome
she's safe and he's behind bars good
morning to you good morning to you we
don't hear about these types of stories
very often but it was here inside this
hotel that that 8 year old was found
along a very busy highway thanks to two
good Samaritans now 51 year old Michael
Webb is in police custody charged with
aggravated kidnapping from a podium last
night police play the dispatch call that
went out when Salem sobotka was found
relieved friends and neighbors eagerly
listened I'd like to give you a hand as
the citizens in this community for
pulling together the way you did at
around 2:20 a.m. police located the
eight-year-old girl nearly eight hours
after she was kidnapped I guess I was
like a cheerleader or something I don't
know because I started scaling
surveillance video captured the moment
Salem was taken Saturday evening police
say her mother jumped into the suspects
car frantically trying to save her the
driver pushed her to the ground and sped
off Miss sweet valiantly fought with the
male that abducted her child so so much
so that she was able to grab a piece of
jewelry off of that male hours after
issuing a statewide Amber Alert two
witnesses reported a tip to police they
had spotted the suspects car in the
parking lot of a hotel where Salem and
her kidnapper were eventually found
police busted in the hotel room door and
took Michael Webb into custody
thank you Jeff King pastor Jeff King was
one of those witnesses
it was like an overjoyed experience and
then like it was just as crazy it was
like adrenaline it was everything so
I feel like God allowed me to be a tool
and that's it police have not announced
a motive and now Webb faces additional
charges Anthony Jericka do we know
anything more about the suspect
well we do know that the suspect
apparently has a criminal history
according to court records last year he
was charged with sexual assault but
according to authorities the accuser
decided she did not want to cooperate
Anthony Jericka thank you so glad Salem
is okay yes we hear that story you think
the outcome may not be good this is
wonderful